to the team that made the move that we
didn't think they were going to make
as justin fields trickled past number
ten
and i was starting to hear maybe the
vikings were going to take justice
14. they love him cargo bears
from the nfc north love him more and
they make the move
up to the giants yes dave gettleman
proves he is capable of trading back
yeah dave
first round pick next year by dropping
down nine spots once he got leap frog
for devonta smith and he got the next
receiver off the board so it worked out
well for the giants to go down to 20.
but the uh bears making that move
gutsy call here's ryan pace the gm of
the bears to break down why they did
what they did
springing up to 11 to get the ohio state
quarterback
matt has spoken to andy dalton tonight
that communication and clarity for us is
really important
andy is our starter and we're going to
have a really good plan in place to
develop justin
and do what's best for our organization
to win games i mean this guy's toughness
on a scale 1 to 10's and 11.
and you just love that about him oh and
then by the way he runs a 4-4-4
you know we talked about this multiple
times leading up to the draft this is
not a trade that gets made without
virginia mccaskey signing off on it
because
what it does is it either gives ryan
payson matt nagy at least two years and
maybe that's what needed to happen
maybe this is the way to get the fans to
simmer down
yeah group that's taken to the playoffs
twice in three years yeah that's right
playoffs have not been a routine aspect
to the bears experience
everybody sit down shut up we got this i
like either that
right or yeah or they are gonna have
themselves a hell of a mess
right if they clean house after this
season because whoever comes in next
year
says justin fields is the quarterback
okay
all right well we'll we'll we'll do what
we can to get the most out of the guy
that i didn't have in my top 30 players
if that's who they end up hiring so i
think good news for payson nagy the way
that pace talked about it
yeah these are guys who expect to be
around and i assume they didn't give up
the 2022 first round pick
without making sure that folks higher up
george mccaskey virginia mccaskey said
we give you the blessing to do this and
we understand this means you guys aren't
going anywhere for at least a couple of
years i would think so too
i mean right that was the big mystery
it's why i had justin fields falling a
little bit because i just wasn't sure
right would the bears give the green
light i don't know mike first off
i really love and respect because you're
right and i know i've been critical of
matinee and his offense and everything
like that
but it's the playoffs two out of three
years they're closer to the top than the
bottom
and it is an overreaction and i do think
the bears fans need to pump the brakes a
little bit
i understand it's not perfect but it's
still been damn good
and hey this is a bold move there's no
doubt about it
now again getting back to like the andy
dalton
uh justin fields converse i mean yeah
okay andy dalton's the starter
right okay sure sure he is until he
throws the first incompletion in game
one or the preseasons when is it
you know when will that be training camp
yeah or trent it's just it's just a
matter of time
and again with justin fields yes you
know my concerns there's some rawness
and things that gotta get fixed with the
throwing
but the running aspect of his game is
very special
and i am intrigued too there again with
matt nagy to see what he can come up
with a little bit
he's going to try to probably infuse his
own style of a running quarterback here
you know andy reedish fake the speed
sweep so everybody going different ways
and
he's going to do that with justin field
so i'm never going to be mad at a team
for going to get their guy
come on we know their quarterback
situation was underwhelming to begin
with
we all were wondering like what are they
going to do something are they really
going to go with andy dalton as a
starter
and uh they answered that last night so
good for them and good for justin fields
too who's been
i know really scrutinized and i'm one of
those guys i get that but i still root
for the human being
and want him to succeed andy dalton has
that 10 million dollar
salary for this year so he is going to
be part of the picture in chicago but
you know they they were in this same
spot with mike glennon four years ago
when they got mitch trubisky that's why
i said pay no attention to the man
behind the curtain
when they were doing that qb1 crap with
andy dalton right and they were saying
he's the starter they had that
tweet he's qb1 yeah he's qb1 until you
draft one
that's that's well that's what he is and
this happens from time to time where a
guy gets a nice contract in free agency
and he's the starter until he's not and
he's the starter for now
and we'll see how long it lasts but yeah
qb one
um okay and uh but that's what yet
that's just what you do it's when in
rome
who that has a veteran quarterback on
the roster
it's different if you don't jaguars make
trevor lawrence qb one
jets make zack wilson qb one the other
three teams
we already have a veteran this is just
part of the ritual this is the rights of
passage for the rookie
to prove himself within the building and
if justin fields can't beat out andy
dalton why the hell did they give up
next year's first round pick to go get
him
that's the that's the first litmus test
here
if you can't beat out andy dalton well
yeah maybe we made himself that's why
that's why he will you're right that's
why he will because it'll be
set up for success to make sure that
happens because you're exactly right
that'll become the theme or the question
then wait he couldn't beat out andy dahl
what the hell's wrong so that that is
going to happen
they're going to make sure that listen
it was a light this is a lightning rod
topic in chicago and for ryan pace and
matt niggy
they got to get everybody off their back
with the quarterback situation i'm mad
i'm mad i didn't
pencil it into them taking justin fields
i really am
you know i i truly am because from their
standpoint
this this those two guys this is the
obvious
pick i mean people in chicago when i go
on their regional sports network or
anything like that
they're pissed about the quarterback
situation they are they're not happy
about it so
now they got a guy that's really got
some special
elite traits about him and let's see if
he can become more of a polished passer
and thrower
and shut up you know the critiques of
guys like me
and i i hope he can but that's a big if
it is
the the the problems he has thrown the
ball are
not easy ones to fix and i don't say
that to be a jerk or anything i'm just
talking about my experience working with
quarterbacks being a quarterback being
around them whatever it is
and that's going to be the big thing to
watch for uh with justin feels when the
preseason starts
but your concern and it was justifiable
how do the bears
agree to essentially guarantee
employment
for a couple of guys that they've
created the impression for the benefit
of the fans that they're on the hot seat
yeah maybe that was just to placate the
fans
yeah because right now the worst thing
that the bears could do
is treat ryan pace and matt nagy like
they are in a
prove it or get the hell out year in
chicago you
are all in for at least two years now
that you've gotten justin fields and
let's see how it works
and the best news for the bears is this
because fields was the fourth
quarterback off the board their trade up
this year
doesn't expose them to multiple
quarterbacks who could end up being
superstars the only guy they have to
worry about being better than justin
fields is mac jones
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports